السلاح الاكثر جدلا حتى الان بين حلفاء
اوكرانيا في الايام القليله الماضيه هو
الدبابات فالسؤال الذي طغى على اجتماع
رمشتاين الالمانيه هو هل داعم اوكرانيا
مستعدون لتزويدها بالدبابات لبرتور
الالمانيه وابرز الامريكيه الاكثر تطورا
وبعد ساعات من الجدل قرر المجتمعون
لامتناع عن هذه الخطوه في الوقت الحالي في
خطوه غير مسبوقه على الرغم من مناشدات
الرئيس الاوكراني المتكرره الامر الذي
اثار فضول المحللين ودفعهم للتساؤل عما
اذا كانت هذه الدبابات تستحق الضجه
فوفقا من الخبراء في موقع 19 للدفاع
والامن القومي فان دبابات ليبرتو ام 1
ابرامز المعنيه لن تغير بالضروره قواعد
اللعبه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا في ساحه القتال
خاصه ان اوكرانيا استلمت بالفعل حزمه ضخمه
من المساعدات العسكريه من الولايات
المتحده وحدها عباره عن 50 مركبه قتال
برادلي وتسعين مركبه ق يا مصفحه من طراز
سترايكر و500 و80 شاحنه مصفحه ام ار اي بي
و350 سياره عسكريه من طراز هامفي ناهيكا
عن 60 الف صاروخ والقائمه الطويله تتوسع
الاهم من موضوع الدبابات هو من الذي
سيقودها فما فائده اي دبابه دون سائق مختص
وفقا للموقع الالكتروني اثبتت اموان
ابرامز فعاليتها اثناء الغزو الامريكي
للعراق فقط لانها كانت جيده مثل الافراد
الذين يناها والذين خضعوا لتدريبات معقده
وطويله بحسب الخبراء فلا يمكن لاي دبابه
ان تكون السبب وراء فوزي اوكرانيا بدون
ذلك
ويخلص موقع 19 ايضا الى ان جميع الدبابات
لها عيوب بقدر ما تتمتع به من امتيازات
فالدبابات الغربيه قد تكون اكثر دقه وتصيب
اهداف الابعاد ولكن بالمقابل فان تيس 2022
لا تزال تتمتع بقدرات هائله تمنحها القوه
لتدمير دبابات المتطوره بالكامل لذا حتى
لو كانت اوكرانيا تمتلك ليبرتو وابرز فان
ذلك لم يكن ليغير من نتائج معركه خيرسون
على ارض الواقع